so let's talk about all of the different
ways that molecules can be transported
across a cellular membrane so perhaps
the most basic the most passive of the
passive transports would be straight-up
diffusion and if you have a small enough
molecule let's say this is molecular
oxygen it's small it doesn't have any
charge it has no polarity that will be
able to diffuse down its concentration
gradient through the cellular membrane
but as we start to talk about things
with more charge or things that might be
larger then we're going to need some
help
now the first type of help is just help
to allow things to flow down their
concentration gradient and that we call
facilitated diffusion we have a whole
video on facilitated diffusion and one
form of facilitated diffusion hey just
open up a tunnel and let things flow
down their concentration gradient we saw
that with the potassium ion channels
where potassium builds up on the inside
of the cell because of the sodium
potassium pump let me just be clear down
here is this is the inside this is the
outside of the cell and then but then
these channels allow the potassium to
flow down their concentration gradient
going to be put in check because of its
charge it's more positive outside but we
talked about that in other videos but
it's just a simple tunnel now sometimes
that tunnel is gated it's only going to
be open if a certain trigger is hit and
we see that on when we talk about
signals going down a neuron
voltage-gated channels once the voltage
hits a certain amount then the channel
opens and then the sodium that has a
higher concentration outside can flow
down its concentration gradient inside
but both of these this is considered
passive transport it's facilitated
diffusion passive transport we're
allowing things to flow down their
concentration gradient you can see here
the sodium is going in or sorry the
potassium is going in the direction of
its concentration gradient it's high
concentration inside low concentration
outside so allowing it to flow down the
concentration gradient here the sodium
is high concentration outside low
concentration inside and this happened
because of the sodium potassium pump but
we're allowing it to now flow down its
concentration gradient now let's talk
about active transport so passive
transport doesn't or doesn't require any
energy to make this stuff happen it's
just about things flowing down their
gradient in active transport
we're either directly using energy
to make something go against its
gradient or we're using some energy from
a previous active transport to to help
facilitate something else going against
this gradient so first let's talk about
primary active transport because this
might be a little bit more easy to think
about or none of them are that daunting
and the best case of this if we're going
about animal cells is the sodium
potassium pump the sodium potassium pump
super important for establishing resting
membrane voltage I guess you could say
resting membrane potential but the the
concentration gradients that establishes
are also very important the sodium
having a it establishes it pumps sodium
ions out of the cell against its
concentration gradient so as we say the
sodium ions already have a higher
concentration outside but it keeps
pumping them out and to do that it needs
to use ATP it breaks up ATP into ADP and
a phosphate group it hydrolyzes it and
so that's why it's sometimes called an
ATPase it's an enzyme that helps break
up ATP but it uses that and it uses that
energy to pump sodium out of the cell
and potassium into the cell and then as
we'll see that sodium that's pumped out
of it that kind of forms a potential
energy because it starts to build a
chemo electrochemical gradient which can
later be used to power secondary active
transport we'll talk about that in a few
seconds now this is an animal cells the
analog in plant cells fungi protists
prokaryotes is the is the proton ATPase
or the proton pump which does the same
thing but it does it instead of doing it
in two directions it does it for protons
it pumps the protons out of the cell
against their concentration gradients so
even though you have a higher
concentration outside than inside it'll
continue to pump them out but to do to
power it it uses ATP to change its
conformation in the right way and so
that's why it's off this is often called
a proton ATPase this is called sodium
potassium ATPase that's our friend the
sodium potassium pump this is called
proton ATPase and you wouldn't see these
in the same in the same cell so maybe
I'll
little line over here this would be in
plants fungi protists things like that
this would be in animal cells but both
of them are actively using energy
they're directly using ATP to transport
things against their concentration
gradient which is why we call it active
transport now because you have these
concentration gradients or these
electrochemical gradients are
established those can then be used a
fuel to do other forms of active
transport and that's what we call
secondary active transport so this right
over here this is my little depiction of
a symporter and this is the sodium
glucose symporter and what it does is it
leverages the sodium flowing down its
concentration gradient and once again
that was established with this sodium
potassium pump so it's flowing down its
concentration gradient but it's
leveraging that energy you can catch
them imagine kind of a you know putting
a little wheel under a waterfall to make
it spin to also make glucose to
transport glucose against its
concentration gradients so the glucose
already has a will have a high
concentration gradient here low over
here but it's transporting glucose
against its concentration gradient we
talked about in other videos and then
another example of secondary active
transport is an anti porter or an it or
an exchanger in the symporter a co
transporter they're both going in the
same direction even though one is going
with its concentration gradient that's
essentially powering it and the other
one is going against its concentration
gradient that's why it's active
transport with an exchanger they're
going in opposite directions so that you
have the sodium calcium ion exchanger
and here the sodium is going down its
concentration gradient and that fuels
taking the calcium ions outside of the
cell against its concentration gradient
so once again anytime something is going
against its concentration gradient and
once again in this case it's calcium
it's going to be active transport
but since the sodium ions the sodium
ions are going in a different direction
than the calcium ions we call this an
anti porter while this right over here
is a co transporter a symporter now you
might say hey well you know is it the
sodium potassium pump isn't this an anti
porter things are going in different
directions and the difference is both of
these this is primary
transport and the sodium-potassium pump
both of these things are going against
their concentration gradient in a true
anti Porter it's really secondary active
transport one of them is going with
their concentration gradient going down
it which is providing the energy to take
the other thing against its
concentration gradient so anyway
hopefully this gives you a high-level
overview of the various forms of
transports and gives you more
appreciation for how beautiful and
intricate and and and and mesmerizing
cellular membranes and all the different
things that cells have to do actually
are